what Doyle has going for him Above All
Above and Beyond is twofold really the
longevity I mean he's eight in his late
80s and last time I played with him I
was I'm like how is he getting better
like I really felt like he was playing
better than he had you know in the
previous years
um but also with Doyle like Doyle had to
figure you know we talked about my
generation having to figure it on her
own I mean he they really had to figure
it out their own like they didn't have
any computer simulation to tell you if
Ace King was a favorite over pocket
sixes they didn't so we know what he did
he would take a deck of cards and they
would deal out sim and they with a
notepad right okay Ace King won and then
they would do like a hundred of them be
like all right ace King won like 53 so
it must be a favorite and he did it
manually you know and he did it in a
time when it was very very difficult and
he's seen poker evolve and change
throughout the years now listen is he
gonna be able to compete against the top
players in the world today absolutely
not you know but how many people he's
the best 88 year old player in the world
by a mile okay that's not even close and
Doyle again he's another guy who plays
all the games he's played high stakes
cash tournaments you name it he's iconic
you know he's The Godfather so there's
also an element to that so the iconic
element like you're a personality in
poker I mean
not to romanticize this thing too much
but
poker is also a game of personalities
I mean it's part of the greatness is
like the uniqueness of the human being
yeah I think also yeah I mean if you
like looking at it from that perspective
in terms of like go like goat in terms
of what you represent yeah Cowboy The
Godfather you know he's been around you
know he played in the 60s and stuff like
that it's just something like incredibly
cool like I often think about if I go
back in time and like visit you know an
era I'd love to go like to Vegas in the
70s and just like I'm PR I already like
I can think of what it would smell like
probably not ideal cigarettes and you
know the leather jackets and just the
vibe of what it must have been like with
the mobsters and things like that you
know he's lived through all that all the
cool movies we've seen like Doyle talks
about some of those films and he's like
yeah that guy off he said he was going
to stab me in my stomach you know he he
knows these people it was he's like a a
source of History really yeah when poker
was uh a game
for the mob and the the degenerates and
all that kind of stuff before
transitioning into professional sport
yeah a professional game yeah so he was
there through the whole thing he's been
there through the whole transition he's
seen it all yeah